in total we've been in Thailand for 10
days and I have read seven books and I'm
going to go through the top lessons that
I learned from the books and I'm also
going to rate them in order from worst
book to the best book that you
absolutely need to read so basically
I'll read seven books so that you don't
have to you do need to read at least two
of them though so the worst book was
this one being a great boss this book
sucked so bad the whilst I was reading
it I was getting angry at times I was
shouting I usually do enjoy the Harvard
Review books but this one I just didn't
enjoy it was so pathetic and politically
correct it just sucked he was just
talking about to make people feel
comfortable in your office as a boss
maybe when you introduce yourself to the
new employees you should uh introduce
yourself with your
pronoun I'm like it was just
PA pathetic book decision book this one
was good more about people skills that
probably than making decisions just some
nice little nuggets easy reading you
know you can maybe just read this while
you're just on the toilet or something
super easy I read this in like about an
hour key to decision making in my
opinion is best case so if I do this
decision this is the best case scenario
and then this is the worst case and
what's the likely case and then when you
look at best case worst case lightly
case then you just have to freaking make
a decision I'm making a financial
investment way up what's the worst case
if the worst case scenario is oh I'll
lose a few thousand but the best case is
I'll make a million and of course I'm
going to go with the decision and just
make the decision this book uh War by
Robert Green it was it was quite good I
like studying ancient war stories and
and philosophies of how to deal with you
know enemies and conflict similar to
Mastery I probably slightly preferred
Mastery by Robert Green but to be honest
if you're going to read Robert Green I
would suggest just reading the
48 Laws of Power I think it's called
Power by Robert greed it's brilliant
brilliant book not because you want to
be powerful a lot of manipulation
techniques in there about how to
manipulate people obviously you don't
want to do that it's not good it's not
good karma it's not good feel and
usually will catch up with you in the
end but the reason I enjoyed the book so
much was because it teaches you how to
watch out for people that do the tricks
on you and you can see be like oh my
good especially when you're in business
you're like oh wow they're doing that
thing that Robert Green talked about a
lot of manipulation techniques really
good this thoroughly enjoyed this this
was incredible raving fans just the
concept of this is incredible so
basically it talks about how you don't
want your customers to be satisfied a
satisfied customer is not enough what
you need is you need raving fans so yeah
this was just brilliant I mean if you've
got if you're in the property business
if you've got tenants you don't want
your tenants to be happy you want your
tenants to be raving fans if um if
you've got if you if you've got
investors if you're a deal sourer and
you're selling to to investors you know
want your investor to be like yeah I'm
happy you want your invested to be like
oh my gosh that deal source is only the
best deal ever I'm madly recommend in
them so yeah just obsessing over your
customers is is is so important in
business cuz then they'll come back
they'll buy more on more products from
you they'll stay with you they'll be
loyal to you they'll spread the word you
really want any successful business
needs to have raving fans and this
raving fans book was incredible all
right next up brilliant book loved
reading this I read the book what they
don't teach you at harage University and
what they don't teach you at Harvard
University was really good so I decided
um to read this book
but they still don't teach you at
Harvard
University I mean I didn't put this down
as my favorite I put the next one down
as my favorite but out of all the books
if I was going to recommend to you if
you're wanting to get into business I
would recommend this one this book it
goes through sales negotiations
management it's just a
brilliant staple you know when you go
for a nice meal and you have like a
roast dinner it's like a nice staple
Meal m Yorkshire pudding with chicken
and and mashed potato that's this this
is like a staple meal there's nothing in
here that I read that was groundbreaking
or like oh it's completely changed the
way I view life in business but it was
just really refreshing if you're
starting out business this is going to
really really help you with the
fundamentals of business I enjoyed this
but my favorite book was this one money
in one lesson this was brilliant I found
this the most fascinating read quite a
quite a slogging way it's quite a thick
book and it's not it's not um you know
it's not big print either so it took me
the longest to read this took me about 2
days out of the 10 days I was here to
read this this book talks about money
money doesn't exist it never has existed
and it never will exist money is just an
idea a concept that everybody plays
along with but actually money doesn't
exist um explains how money came off the
gold standard 1931 in England 1971 in
America and how money effectively is
just an IOU you know it's not even on
the gold standard uh he explains central
banks how they work um goes into masses
of detail on quantitive easing uh
government bonds fractional Reserve
banking the First Central Bank that ever
existed in Sweden and how the guy that
set it up they did actually go into
prison for fraud but now it's a standard
thing this I found this just fascina as
somebody that is an investor and
somebody that is you know student of
money and what money is this was
brilliant so this was my number one this
one there absolutely brilliant get it
think the six books I'm going to read
one more I'm going to buy something at
the airport and I'm going to read one
more book on the plane on the way home
but I don't know what that book is
[Music]
yet